[Music]
tis the season for baubles and bling I'm
Sophia Lacy with et and before the start
of engagement season we're looking back
at our favorite celebrity engagement
rings of 2016 starting with one of the
biggest Russell Wilson popped the
question to Sierra with a megawatt 16
carat ring in March
now who could top that sparkler besides
that's kind of a big deal
yep Queen Mariah Carey said yes to a 35
carat diamond and platinum ring from
Australian billionaire James Packer and
though they are no longer an item
meanies still hanging on to that 10
million dollar ring so engage Marines
don't always lead to wedded bliss but
for Rob Kardashian and blac Chyna it did
lead to a beautiful baby girl named
dream and an ongoing on-again off-again
relationship as for this private couple
rosie huntington-whiteley and jason
statham quietly revealed their
engagement on the Golden Globes red
carpet with Rosie showing off a very
chic Neil Lane rim but Jason still
played it coy what are you gonna pop the
question
come on so pretty I just you know she's
real video you'll see really it's gonna
be soon you'll Fonda proving that
engagement rings are only a girl's game
it's perfect co-stars Anna camp and
Skylar Astin swapped bands before their
wedding for her a delicate rose gold
stunner for him a simple braided style
Emma Slater's unique pink sapphire stone
weighs in at 4 carats and is surrounded
by counter mccann a hundred and fifteen
micro pave diamonds and boy do they
shine
I've been colored stones were actually a
huge trend this year and a man Sasha
totally nailed that look which was your
favorite ring of 2016 let me know in the
comments and on twitter i'm at sobytia'
Lacey bye for now
[Music]